crucial victory for him correct tell us
a bit about this game that we're
watching right now can you discern
anything in the position
what's happening
well you don't have it on your board
because otherwise black should be
winning yes yes
but on the other hand it's not clear how
white can avoid the exchange of Rooks
maybe Rook takes C6 F3 Rook C7 but then
there's
then there's at least Rook F7 for black
at least you say okay at least maybe at
most as well
but maybe there's also Rook F5 I'm not
sure look at five there's again this
check Rook C8 and if not look if it if I
try King F7 uh Knight D6 check King E6
Knight takes F5
uh you can't play F2 because of Knight
E3 and if you play King takes F5 there's
Bishop D4 and ff2 Rook f8 so black
should go for a draw yeah in that case
yeah yeah
wow okay
and Alice has 11 seconds
this one was a group draw great by the
way defensive skills by Justin Wang no
question about it yeah he was under
pressure and we have a soul leader in
the Juniors right now it's Artur Goa yes
all right let's get back to to Alice
perhaps just to
well close the last few uh moves before
the time control rookie eight okay
okay I'm really having a hard time
understanding what the heck is going on
we can tweet these players Rook E8 why
is Alice doing Bishop D4 maybe I mean
isn't she helping white coordinate her
pieces I don't know I don't know yes sir
Knight is coming with the tempo
she used to make chess last move to get
then the extra 30 minutes one more move
okay one more D4
how much she she let her cloth take down
to what 10 seconds 10 seconds right now
seconds and F3 and she's good
and she's made time control
well uh let's talk to our guest uh
Christian back to you well yes sir you
weren't understanding anything that one
but we didn't understand anything from
this game with the engine is much easier
to understand things but tell us your
perspective Kirk well okay I was out of
book quite early in this game I think
after age six I didn't know what to do
because I didn't expect this line when I
played the time on off
um
I mean something like this yeah yeah I
played Knight C4 quite quickly but I
suppose it was a mistake I I realized
quite after my position was extremely
difficult to play yes but these
positions are also never easy it's very
risky opening both sides always in these
open Sicilian battles when did you feel
like you're starting to turn the tide in
this one
it's hard to say I mean I think I was
completely lost at some point in this
game I was very lucky in the
complications the positions spiraled out
of control for him and by the way by the
way instead of B4
um I was thinking maybe I could play
something else I was thinking of Knight
D5
Knight takes D5
maybe B3 let's say queen C7
yes I expect this this is the problem
white just eventually crashes through in
the long run yeah it's just if white
just keeps sacrificing forward black
cannot defend the main problem is
there's no side of the board where
Black's King is safe exactly and he was
trying to do that he was trying to crash
yeah he actually understood the spirit
of the opening he was trying to play in
this sacrificial Reckless manner but the
problem was uh you also have to be
precise exactly as well exactly
take take by the way I saw after Queen
D3 I could go Queen takes D3 yes and go
into that end game and I saw of course
now I'm no longer lost but this is an
end game I cannot win at all so I was
just rather going to into the
complications and go to this end game
where I can't win keep the pieces on the
board yeah give him some room to make
errors yeah I was actually not surprised
by the evaluation during the game I
thought it could be something like that
but if he can win by force uh the
position still complicated and I'm a
piece up and I think this is the only
move did you spot this move during the
game the screen me too let me remember
um what if if Knight F6 Rook G7 it just
keeps continuing right the attack yeah
and if Queen c6f takes C6 hanging A4
yeah okay
yeah yeah this is impossible to play
over the board and he played Bishop to
B6 and finally at this point you're
starting to why is Queen B5 stronger
um there was some problems after uh Rook
G6 if you take he could have taken with
the Rook yeah this position is so
unclear because there's so many moves
going on I wasn't sure and my opponent
was getting low on time completely wild
and that was part of your strategy of
course right F take C6 Queen to B5 and
after this
you're finally stabilizing yeah
stabilizing kind of a way to to say that
yeah King to E6 Queen to G6 she he he's
just running away of fire running out of
Firepower and he will look up nicely
done
Kirk you've had some difficult games in
the last couple of rounds you had a
beautiful position against Justin Wang
out of the opening yesterday against
abhimani how did you recover after those
hiccups I mean I was actually quite
lucky in today's game I would say that
the position spiraled out of control and
I I won the game but balances out a
little bit yeah definitely balances out
uh my earlier games uh I mean my game in
round four was quite painful I died
without any counter plays just complete
Suffocation
um yeah my game against Justin Wenger I
missed this 95 possibility Bishop takes
uh F6 followed by 95 in the opening so
that was a missed opportunity and yeah
in my game yesterday okay I I see that I
had a chance to win but I was less upset
because that position was very difficult
to win already for White and the whole
time I thought it was a fortress but
it's a very useful concept to know about
in the future that maneuver yeah that's
great wow correct congratulations always
taking something positive out of your
games congratulations we'll see you in
the next couple of days thank you and
our congratulations to you as well uh
Kirk nicely done and